[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how about we just don't say anything
more
and then we bring in the popular jay
billis is that okay
how about we do that jay thank you for
getting up uh after last night's game
where do you want to start well it
sounds like you could use some legal
representation
i'd be happy to help you with your
trademark copyright issues
how are you on trademark and copyright
infringement
pretty good actually i i actually had a
case uh
a pretty good case in trademark
copyright okay
we came up with tampa bay we tweeted it
out
put it on our show we had a t-shirts
made and then we heard from
tom brady's camp a cease and desist
did we have any legal grounds to stand
on
you probably did but uh that's that's a
normal practice for people that are
trying to protect intellectual property
they have to
you know they send a cease and desist
and they might take further action if
they don't they
they run the risk of losing their their
trademark copyright rights
so if you would have pushed back who
knows where it would have been but
usually what people do is they just kind
of stop because they don't want to deal
with this
yeah and that's the easiest thing but i
don't know i don't know whether tom
brady or his companies have
trademarked that uh or or they have
copyright um protection for it
they trademarked it after we came up
with it
wow that that would be a that would be a
fun fight let's i say let's roll up our
sleeves no no because you're friends
with great
terrific no remember tom stayed over
your house
would you be willing that doesn't make
us friends that this is money man
okay are you willing to take on augusta
because we got a cease and desist from
augusta
that's different i'd like to play there
again
all right that's all i needed you for
jay thanks for coming on
uh how would you describe the first five
minutes of last night
a beatdown baylor just crawled
into gonzaga and just was just i mean
the physical
presence they had on the floor they
seemed bigger
seemed stronger and uh and they just
took everything from gonzaga it wasn't
like
you know i think most of us going into
the game and said you know gonzaga needs
to take care of the ball
that baylor forces a turnover on almost
25 percent of their opponent's
possessions
uh during the year and but but it wasn't
like gonzaga
was throwing the ball away baylor was
taking it from him
and there's a difference and they could
you know gonzaga couldn't run anything
they couldn't get they they basically
had their backs turned
in trying to run some sort of offense so
while all of us were talking about maybe
the the best passing and cutting team
we've seen and i don't know how long uh
because who ranks that stuff but i
couldn't i couldn't remember anybody
better
uh they couldn't see the cutters because
they were just overwhelmed with ball
pressure and pushed further out drew
timmy was trying to
drive some of the big guys um and he
you know he lost the ball on on occasion
i think he turned it over three times in
the first 10 minutes
and then baylor just went after whatever
matchup they liked
and gonzaga was switching and drew timmy
switches out on macy o teague or
something like that and they're like
okay here we go and just went after it
was like an nba team
uh going after a euroleague team are we
gonna remember
baylor winning a championship or are we
gonna this year with uh or gonzaga
with uh you know suggs is game winner to
beat ucla like 15 years from now
are we when we think of this year what
do you think we're going to remember
i think we'll remember both i mean i
think we'll remember gonzaga as
as being a great team that was right
there to do something that hasn't been
done in 45 years and
and falling short obviously and you'll
always remember the champion
uh and baylor like this year dan i mean
you you probably heard it and said it as
much as i did
uh that gonzaga and baylor were the top
tier of the game they had separated
themselves early in the season they were
the best teams
and when baylor i believe this to be
true that if baylor had not gone through
that covet pause they had i think it was
in february
where they were they were off for 18
days and it wasn't like it was a contact
tracing
covet pause they had eight or nine guys
on their team that had the virus
so it knocked them sideways and they
weren't the same team when they came
back initially i did their second game
back i think it was at kansas
and and they got beat pretty good there
and i remember saying during the game
like this is not the baylor team we've
seen this is the coveted baylor team and
getting criticized for we are making
excuses kansas is a better team and i'm
like
no they're not i mean they're winning
but they're not the better team like
come on
uh you can't you can't ignore what we've
seen
and and what we may see again and then
uh in the in the ncaa tournament it was
gonzaga and baylor
and that's pretty much it those were the
two best teams
i just didn't anticipate uh gonzaga
getting
hit like that like so i mean you saw the
game so it when it when they knocked it
to 10 when gonzaga got it down to 10 at
halftime
i was saying okay that's a manageable
number like we we could see that
we could see they can do this and then
jared butler hit a couple threes to
start the second half you're like okay
whatever crack there was in that door it
is now
shut the game was over after the first
three minutes of the second half
we're always looking to replicate the
champions a style that champions have
nfl it happens all the time but can you
replicate
what baylor does they they led the
nation in three-point
field goal percentage i think the only
other national title team to do that was
indiana back with steve alford
maybe the first year they had the
three-point shot can you
can you replicate what they did
yeah um but you're gonna have to have
great guards that can
defend at that high of a level like i
think their three-point shooting was a
big factor
obviously but it wasn't the only factor
that
early on in the season i think we had
identified baylor as having the best
defensive back court in the country
and and i'm not sure it was a close call
uh
and with davion mitchell like he he's a
lottery pick that guy
is the real deal um he's a he's unique
in that
he is unbelievably strong and uh
and he's unbelievably explosive he's got
another gear
and he's he's got leverage he stays in
front of you
uh really an incredible defender it's no
wonder he was the national defensive
player of the year with the way he
affects the game
uh but baylor was good last year like
they were a number one seed last year
before the tournament got called off i
don't think they were a no-brainer to
win it
uh but but they could have won it and
they've been knocking on this door for
quite a while now
and but so is gonzaga that that's kind
of the funny thing i gonzaga is the more
interesting case to me
because baylor is a power five team with
a you know power five football and all
that stuff
gonzaga has been to six straight sweet
16s sixth straight
there's only a couple other programs
that have done that in the game's
history they've won
they've won 30 or more including last
year
in five straight years that's never been
done before ever
and and so we're talking about and
they've been to i think it's four of the
last six
elite eights um and two of the last four
title games that's not a fluke like this
is not some little mid major that they
play
um you know they they play a an easier
schedule therefore they're more like
that's just not fair and people are
saying that now i mean you see it on
social media told you they
they were a fraud like really really
um they're really good and they're gonna
be just as good next year because
they've got
big time players like now they're
starting to recruit
the superstar high school players and
they've always gotten transfers
but they're not going to go away either
so we're going to see this
we could very likely see this again not
just with these two teams but gonzaga is
not going anywhere
he's jay billis from the mothership what
about the transfer portal
uh vital's been you know railing on this
that we got all of these players are
able to transfer
uh where do you stand on this i don't
think the
execution of the portal is a very good
idea dan but this this is a result of
two things
one it's a result of coaches complaining
about poaching
you know the idea that uh they had a
player on their roster
that the player was interested in
leaving somebody contacted another
school and said do you have a spa do you
have space available and they kind of
negotiated the player's way out
didn't like that didn't like the fact
the player didn't come into their office
sit down have a heart-to-heart with good
old coach and
you know let's let's talk this out and
let's let's battle through adversity and
all that stuff
um so the so the coaches didn't like it
well now they got the transfer portal so
the players are telling them and they
just go
and uh and it's an it's kind of an open
invitation to leave
um and we're gonna see more of it uh so
the transfer market is here to stay
but the other part of it is the ncaa
cannot justify
this year in residence thing having it
having a player sit out
like think about this one in high school
you have no college experience at all
and they expect you to make a binding
decision on where you go to college
but after you've been in college and
you've experienced it
then you can't be trusted to leave and
make your decision
based upon your having college
experience look i know what it's like to
play for this guy i don't want to do it
anymore
and uh nope can't be trusted you got to
play through adversity
my parents told me to do it uh my
parents wouldn't let me transfer
well then talk to the parents and tell
the parents tell your kid not to
transfer
but but this whole thing and then the
ncaa didn't want to
uh they don't want to argue over the
year in residence anymore which was an
old vestige when there was freshman
ineligibility
because they want to argue about money
like that their stance on transferring
could hurt them in court while they're
arguing about money
and and who knows what's going to happen
with the u.s supreme court in the next
month and a half when they come down
with their decision in the alston case
but i think we've seen amateurism
uh it's it's certainly if it's not on
life support
you know somebody's got their hand on
the plug you know
it's going to get pulled at some point
now whether that whether it gets pulled
soon
i don't know but uh but it's not going
to last much longer it just can't
but also you have this situation where
players wanted to meet with the ncaa
president mark emirate
and here they are in indianapolis and
then he says you know we can meet after
like where are we headed here jay in the
next year or so or
is it going to be sooner than that or is
it going to be later than that that we
see maybe some kind of change well first
of all emer emert did say he would meet
with the players there was some sort of
miscommunication there and it was
it was reported that it would be after
but he said he'd meet with them when
their schedules
could do it so he never said he wouldn't
would meet with him during the
tournament
um but but meeting with him is useless
um
there's nothing nothing he can or will
do uh he
i think to say that he has been a
failure
as ncaa president would be an
understatement he's been a colossal
failure
but where we're headed is the players
are going to have
the same rights going forward as
literally everybody else
like you know the one thing that the
ncaa has never done
is they've never evolved with the
changing times the only way they've
evolved
is by saying hey we need to evolve
in our making money but we can't evolve
with
the players and the rest of like they're
going to stay where they are
but everything else we're going to
evolve with the times and look i love
coaches as much as anybody
it may sound like i don't when i'm i'm
talking about them right now
but i i've grown a little tired of
listening to coaches saying you know
when i got into coaching
it was i didn't get into it for money
you know well
but you took the money you know you
didn't turn down the money
you know everybody says that well this
is about the kids they call them kids
all the time
when they're adults it's it's called
men's basketball and women's basketball
they're not kids they're adults and if
we can sell them for billions of dollars
if they're old enough to sell
they're old enough to bargain for their
fair market value
and just the nil thing which everybody
seems to think is a compromise it's
going to lead to
an open open market at some point
because it has to
but you know the the argument now is
only zion williamson and trevor lawrence
are going to make money everybody
that's not true uh women are gonna make
a ton of money
people you've never heard of because
we're old men
like this system has been run by old
white men for long enough
and it needs to open up and evolve and
and the athletes need to be allowed uh
to
act in the marketplace just like
literally everyone else because as you
know dan
uh far more non-athletes get
scholarships than athletes
and and there's no non-athlete that is
told what they can earn or accept in the
marketplace by
by virtue of being a student or by
virtue of accepting a scholarship
like do we call that pay when a
non-athlete gets a scholarship
well you shouldn't get anything more
because you get a scholar like that's
absurd
it's absurd to tell a non-athlete that
and it's absurd to tell an athlete that
and look if an individual school doesn't
want to pay then don't pay
just like you don't have to pay your
coaches millions of dollars you don't
have to build facilities you don't have
to have a hospital don't do any of that
if you don't want to
but but you know banding together like a
as a cartel which the ncaa
is um that's just not going to work in
the long run it's amazing it's worked
this long
but if you if you try to read tea leaves
from the supreme court's questioning and
oral argument about a week ago uh
they're not buying it
uh unless they were just stress testing
an argument and they're all on the other
side of it
um long time court observers have said
they didn't feel the argument
was a good thing for the ncaa uh
i love you fired up uh have a good off
season
whatever that is jay uh have a good off
season
sounds like i'm gonna be jumping into
court to protect you
from these evil evil tom brady send you
cease and desist
doesn't he have enough money he can't
let you make a t-shirt i don't even know
if he knows
that i'm the one who came up with the
t-shirt oh he knows dan
he's sitting there you think you know
stroking a hairless cat
you know kind of with an evil laugh
patrick will not have it probably has a
pinky ring oh you're turn right yeah he
got a super bowl ring for his pinky and
he's got it right there like that
controlling the world yes uh thank you
jay
good to see you bud that's jay bilas
from the mothership